welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and who is the most powerful
Avenger at risk now that secret Invasion
has confirmed enhanced super Scrolls
from the DNA of Groot color City and
frost beasts extremist soldiers are all
on the table do we need to be on the
lookout for scroll wizard Wongs scroll
Spider-Mans scroll Hulks and would they
just be called skroks let's explain what
super scrolls are and why the secret
Invasion series is altering somewhat
from their origin process in the comics
here to help me do this is our inside
Marvel co-host and secret Invasion
Comics expert Hector Navarro yo Eric
thanks so much for having me I'm ready
to get into some Scrolls knee deep in
Scrolls oh we're lousy with Scrolls here
and a reminder to everyone new rockstars
is now three channels this main channel
for Easter egg breakdowns and answers to
your burning questions my channel the
Deep dive for deeper analyzes and
classic titles you love and a break room
which is the new home of our inside
Marvel reactions subscribe to all three
and support us with a squirrel inspired
shirt at nerdrive.shop alright Hector uh
catch us up on what super scrolls are in
the comics absolutely so the first Super
scroll appeared in the Marvel Comics
Universe in issue number 18 of the
Fantastic Four all the way back in 1963.
it was created by Jack the king Kirby
and Stan Lee and the character's origin
story is pretty great coming off of the
humiliating defeat of the Scrolls thanks
to the Fantastic Four including that
famous ending where Reed Richards
brainwashed a few scroll stragglers to
think they were Earth cows the scroll
Emperor vowed revenge and used his
people's top scientists to develop a
super weapon that would come back and
defeat the Fantastic Four that super
weapon was clert who would be
biologically engineered to Encompass all
of the Fantastic Four's abilities Mr
Fantastic stretching invisible girl
later woman's invisibility the human
torches flame powers and the things
rock-like skin and super strength to
become the first Super scroll Plus on
top of those power sets he also had some
extras like his regular scroll
shape-shifting abilities and a beam from
his eyes that could hypnotize people
clert went on to lose against the
Fantastic Four and later The Avengers
Captain Marvel Spider-Man and even Iron
Fist but he eventually became a bit of
an anti-hero siding with the cree
against an even bigger Cosmic threat
there have been other super Scrolls
since kalart but he's got the longest
and most interesting dramatic story in
the comics so we saw a super powered
version of this villain teased in the
second Fantastic Four movie Rise of the
Silver Surfer everybody remembers that
great movie but the current Marvel
Cinematic Universe has never seen a
super scroll one thing the second
episode of secret Invasion did give us
is Talos name-dropping Emperor drogue
who is in charge of a colony of Scrolls
while the rest over a million have fled
to Earth that's all we know about the
scroll emperor in the MCU for now but
can we look to the comics to see if we
can learn more not really no but there
is a scroll character named drogue fenu
edu who isn't the emperor but a royal
priest of the Sciences whose incredible
intellect helped to the scroll Empire
study the DNA of a few captured Earth
Heroes which later factored majorly into
Queen veranke's plans for Earth in the
secret Invasion comic droga was a
scientist and maybe this reference is a
hint towards what the MCU scroll
Emperor's priorities might be but more
likely emperor drogue in the MCU is
closer to Classic skrull Emperor Doric
VII who dealt with the early days of the
Fantastic Four and the Avengers in the
comics and who initially set in motion
the super scroll program the question is
in the MCU is graphic acting on his own
behalf or in cooperation with Emperor
drogue and his Colony good question to
pose Eric I think good question to pose
back to the comics when Queen veranke
launched her Invasion forces clert was
off doing his own thing dealing with
Nova Richard Ryder and then later
Jennifer Walter Sheila but the Scrolls
had other super Scrolls they dumped in
the heart of New York City it's girls
who weren't just duplicating the powers
of the Fantastic Four but dozens of
Earth's hero was in really cool
combinations in fact in the lead-up to
the public part of the secret Invasion
comic Tony Stark and his fellow members
of the Illuminati discovered that Black
Bolt himself black agar baltagon had
been replaced by one of these new super
Scrolls so here's hoping for an Anson
Mount cameo in the show oh yikes all you
need is like a good guy's scroll want to
maximoff to seal that mouth shut and
then completely
now Summer's Beach season in but being
outside has made me realize that your
scalp is getting sunburned more than
usual might be time to start using keeps
to deal with your hair loss keeps offers
clinically proven research-backed
treatments to stop hair loss and improve
hair growth two out of three guys will
experience hair loss by the time they're
35 but with keeps you can get quality
expert care without ever visiting a
doctor's office or a pharmacy all of the
keeps treatment plans are recommended by
a licensed medical provider and
delivered straight to your door at about
half the cost of a traditional Pharmacy
each treatment plan comes with a full
year of unlimited messaging so that you
can connect with your medical provider
about anything anytime keeps has a
network of Expert Medical advisors
prescribers and Care Specialists to
support you in making your hair goals a
reality whether you're looking to
prevent hair loss stimulate hair growth
or just take better care of the hair
that you have keeps has you covered hair
loss stops with keeps to get a special
offer go to keeps.com new rockstars or
click the link in the description that's
k-e-e-p-s.com Slash new rockstars but
actually let's talk about how they're
doing super slow a bit differently on
the show yeah we talked about this in
the breakdown when Gaia looks at the
computer screen and she Scrolls through
some of the scroll scroll scroll
scrolling and we just see four of them
but there might be more that's what's
interesting about it she just got caught
when she's halfway down the you know she
had to turn off the monitor I'm just
doing homework I'm looking at porn
obviously so what do we see we see Groot
and they label him you know as we know
him four glasses from Planet X but what
was interesting is the image shows that
this was acquired from Earth so this is
probably some leftover loose wood bark
from the Battle of wakanda the battle of
Earth in New York and it looks like
there's like a little heart rate monitor
and like a pulse so like there's still a
living part of Groot that's still in
this wood which is just a little
disturbing also of the frost Beast the
carnivorous repto mammal we saw the
frost piece on yotenheim the first Thor
movie and in the events of 2013's Thor
the Dark World when a frost piece was
transported to London from the events of
the convergence and was left there so
presumably this is that same exact Frost
beast and this also could have been
gathered from The Shield archives as it
was them who cleaned up the a mess in
the dark world as we saw in Agents of
Shield Season one that's right that's
right could be Canon we don't know yet
we don't know yet there's still time to
confirm it as Canon call obsidian also
on this list remember this guy part of
thanos's black order and infinity War
arm got chopped off by Wong via a portal
hacky sacked around by Bruce Banner this
photo seems to show that severed hand on
ice and we know from the trailer footage
that there is like a we're gonna see a
case open up with that hand and then
extremists you know them from Iron Man 3
also from the fighting pit in Shang Chi
these are the the soldiers who can get
this combustible fiery limb regenerating
Tech that alters Killian and aim put
into them so we got like a fiery form
but that's as far as we get but what was
interesting here is that all their DNA
is listed as like DNA like they had to
label it that way that it was DNA based
suggesting that there may be beans
outside of Earth's orbit that are not
DNA based that are cop capable of being
copied that way it's just like kind of
an interesting distinction of like
carbon vs silicon based life form and it
just makes you wonder could the
squirrels replicate like an eternal
could they replicate a Celestial could
they replicate like an Asgardian uh I
assume as Guardians have DNA but it just
kind of like puts a distinction there
yeah I think in the MCU it's called GNA
for the asgardians that's Godly dyro
nucleic acid what does DNA stand for
again nailed it you nailed nailed it so
they also give us some new rules of MCU
Scrolls on this show like Scrolls can
also assimilate the memories of their
prey so any skills that are rooted in
memory or muscle memory learned over a
lifetime could also be replicated even
without the DNA so for example the
Mystic Arts shung Chi's martial arts
skills yeah so I think that opens up
Wong doctor strange and shung Chi and
anybody else who are their friends who
have similar skill sets could all be
vulnerable to scroll replication without
being super Scrolls it's also important
to know too that the MCU has even
established that other space-faring
Galactic beings like the one that we saw
in the sort of old school version of the
Guardians of the Galaxy in James Gunn's
films can also do sorcery right that one
character that had the sort of so krylar
absolutely so Scrolls and this also goes
to the comics are a group within the
Marvel Comics universe that have also
used sorcery and the Mystic Arts in
their experimentation in their
scientific experimentation even so
that's definitely a possibility Eric
absolutely yeah it's interesting that
they call it the Harvest Capital H
Harvest this is kind of a mystical not
so much scientific but like a mystical
religious ritual that they're going
through to do this so it's just kind of
an interesting way that they look at it
and it is very much based on DNA and
blood which to me reminds me of that
stolen blood plot line that we saw in
She-Hulk with the Intelligentsia you
could see a skrullified Mark Ruffalo
Bruce Banner Hulk you could see a
skrullified Jen Walters She-Hulk so if
you're gonna see super powered super
Scrolls of familiar faces who have been
with us since the beginning I think Mark
Ruffalo is at the top of that list that
we really gotta worry about he's already
green you know you don't really have to
change that much yeah I think they have
to do a step above just the regular
super soldier strength because Scrolls
already have super strength so to make
it distinct from that you have to do
someone who has something beyond that
yeah and I and I would not be surprised
Eric if some Scrolls also infiltrated
the Intelligentsia pretending or
actually being misogynist to get access
to that Jennifer Walters blood we don't
know how likely it is that the scroll
can get access to that and also the end
of the She-Hulk show with its fourth
wall breaking in reality warping we
don't even know if that DNA or blood was
still available or if it was something
to sort of erase from the timeline but
maybe if some Scrolls could get to it by
pretending that they were men's rights
activists then you know everything's on
the table absolutely I mean I think it's
very likely that like agent Cleary or
some of the other people from the dodc
there's got to be a scroll in the mix
somewhere there and that's that's where
we're going to get some of this some of
these leaks but an important detail that
they established is that Scrolls and
this show are immune to radiation
radiation doesn't really affect their
DNA so I think that brings up some
interesting implications for Monica
Rambo Carol Danvers and Kamala Khan
because they all use Cosmic radiation as
part of their power sets so that might
make them immune to any scroll
duplication because squirrels would need
to be able to manipulate radiation if
radiation just kind of bounces off them
or goes straight through them they
aren't able to absorb it in the way that
Carol Kamala and Monica do that's an
excellent point I mean what could this
mean for the future of the MCU and the
Scrolls stories within the MCU uh what
does it mean for the Fantastic Four what
does it mean for the Marvels we're about
to get into that right now Eric nicely
done great segue to the Future
that I made that you set me up for and I
spiked it teamwork there it is so we're
at the future now we're at the potential
future of the MCU graphic and his forces
are as angry with human Heroes Nick Fury
and Carol Danvers as in the comics the
Scrolls were with the Fantastic Four
leading to graphic developing a weapon
to potentially quote make them stronger
so we know the super scroll is
definitely in development but does this
mean the Fantastic Four themselves will
show up in the secret Invasion show how
could those characters be related to
what's going on now if in the MCU they
have not been introduced yet well check
this out we might get a reverse
engineered Fantastic Four whereas
instead of the super scroll being based
on the powers of the four we might get
the powers of the four based on what we
see with a super scroll picture this at
the end of the six episode series and
the actions of at least one super scroll
maybe more seemingly powered by groot's
stretching the frost beasts Mastery of
transparent ice I know that's a bit of a
stretch but come with me on this call
obsidian strength and durability and the
extremist soldiers hot fiery core we may
see the Scrolls scientific data seized
by Fury and saber placed on the orbiting
station for safe keeping a station that
we know Monica Rambo may be working on
because of the Marvel's trailer and
Monica who may or may not already know
sword super scientist Reed Richards
depending on if you believe he was the
one she called up in one division to
make her a kick-ass Scarlet Witch
barrier vehicle maybe Reed Richards and
three other qualified astronauts get
transferred to the saber station and end
up in an accident that gives them Powers
based on the very DNA samples the
Scrolls already collected instead of the
straightforward cosmic rays we see the
Fantastic Four get their abilities from
in the comics we might see a more
detailed explanation in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe which makes it even
more tragic that Reed Richards can't
reverse the effects and turn his
monstrous best friend back into human
Ben Grimm also because in the comics
clert the first Super scroll was
involved with the murder of Dr Franklin
storm father of Susan and Johnny Storm
we may see the Fallout of an MCU super
scroll or gravic himself in this way in
an upcoming Fantastic Four movie or
story maybe if a super scroll kills more
innocent people in the MCU maybe on
American soil doesn't have to be we will
later learn that one of those people was
Franklin storm further connecting the
secret Invasion series with the mcu's
Fantastic Four wow and now uh that is an
interesting Theory I I think we are a
few years out from the new Fantastic
Four right and we need Heroes to take on
the Scrolls and the super Scrolls alike
so I think our best bet for the time
being may just be radiation empowered
Heroes like Harold Danvers Monica Rambo
Kamala Khan aka the Marvels because that
is the next big title coming out Nick
Fury is going to be in both of these
titles and I think that sets it up
perfectly but I think to justify
bringing them in you would have to
escalate to Wong or some kind of
sorcerer being turned into a scroll
which you wouldn't need to to do through
the super scroll process if you're just
bringing in their memories meanwhile you
have a Hulk super scroll a super stroke
I think that's that's where it's going
to escalate to
incredible squirrel it's very likely you
know anything is on the table at this
point anyone can be a scroll and the
Scrolls could potentially with this
super scroll information duplicate any
hero that we've already come to know and
love in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
but like you've been saying Eric
especially the humans who just have a
technical knowledge a learned ability
like Wong and the other sorcerer Supreme
okay well let us know down below what
super scroll you want to see on this
show keep in mind I don't know if it's
going to be an Asgardian that's it's
going to be a tough they only have so
much budget for the show only six
episodes but but we're kids and we can
dream hey a reminder to subscribe to all
three of our channels in the new
rockstars Network and it can support us
by grabbing some merch and nerdriot.com
follow Hector over at Heroes reforged
you can follow me at iavas and follow
new Rockstar subscribe to new rockstars
more announcements everything you love
thanks for watching everyone thanks
Hector and we'll talk soon see you next
time everybody bye
[Music]
thank you